Ras and Jai are sitting selling tea and coffee to help you. They came
from Gaza. We
have nothing. We are neither conscious nor
need. I get things to sell. I help my
brothers with the money I earn from them. This one brings things for my brothers and I
give them money. We got out of Gaza
with difficulty. The
tanks were beside us and they were kidnapping and throwing
missiles.
I mentioned my cousins, my uncles, my aunt, my aunt, and
all of my relatives, and I
miss her neighborhood, too. I miss everything about us here in
the zone. I hope the war will end and I can rest in peace.
[Music] It is
difficult for us to light firewood. We
buy firewood for 30 shekels when we fire, and cardboard and paper
and night to
light gas and nothing else.
Fire on fire by doing everything